bonjour à tous les deux
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
en direct ce matin sur rtl france pour
débattre de ce plan d'investissement de
30 milliards que va nous présenter à
emmanuel macron à partir de 10 heures
quel intérêt de présenter ce plan
d'investissement à six mois de la
présidentielle sachant qu'il ne sera pas
forcément
réélu emmanuel macron et que ce plan
risque de passer aux oubliettes
bruno bonnell première question pour
vous
d'abord effectivement vous avez raison
de dire qu'on est à six mois d'une
présidentielle et qu'on souhaite
effectivement la réélection du de de
notre président actuel mais au-delà de
ça je pense que il faut se rappeler
qu'il ya eu trois étapes depuis c'est
des normes crise sanitaire que nous
avons vécu et bénite première étape de
protection et toutes les difficultés
qu'on a connu il ya la deuxième étape de
relance de l'économie dont d'abord il
fallait protéger et les structures et
les emplois il fallait maintenant faire
un plan de relance qui a été fait avec
la modernisation 100 milliards pour la
modernisation des entreprises et et
garder la dynamique de croissance 6 3%
cette année c'est loin d'être
négligeable et là il faut anticiper faut
regarder devant d'où le plan france 2030
pour pour pour investir 30 milliards les
nouvelles technologies afin de préserver
non pas de l'emploi existant mais se
projeter dans les nouveaux métiers pour
demain l'espace le nucléaire la
biopharmacie et donc des secteurs dans
laquelle la france doit retrouver une
avance qu'elle avait dans ces domaines
avant avant probablement les trente
dernières années réindustrialiser la
france franck allisio quel est votre
point de vue sur ce plan france 2030
vous y croyez
on nous refait le coup à chaque veille
d'élection présidentielle
il y a un plan de relance qui est en
réalité un plan de campagne électorale
françois hollande avait fait le coup
avant de se retirer nicolas sarkozy fait
le coup chaque président de la
république au pouvoir avant d'être élu
fait un pseudo plan de relance
ça coûte rien puisque cfa ça ne coûte
rien parce que c'est payé par nous c'est
payé par la dette s'est payé ça sera
payée demain par les impôts c'est payé
par un faux seins faux prêts de l'union
européenne qui sera remboursé beaucoup
beaucoup plus cher puisqu'en grosso modo
l'union européenne a donné 40 milliards
et on va devoir rembourser 60 7
milliards à l'époque des états et des
c'est véritablement n'importe quoi et
donc donc voilà à partir de là on est
dans quelque chose de très classique peu
efficace et qui de toute manière n'aura
pas cessé s'engager pour pour pas
grand-chose à aa pas très cher puisque
puisque le président s'engage pour les
années à venir année dans lesquels ben
il ne sera peut-être plus président de
la république bruno bonnell la question
du financement de ce plan
d'investissement il n'est pas inscrit
dans le budget 2022 ça va être amendé à
la fin du mois c'est ça comment ça va se
passer
déjà c'est un plan qui est sur une
dizaine d'années donc c'est un plan qui
va pas sortir comme ça des caisses de
main et aider ce plf oui il y aura des
crédits qui seront qui seront affectés
donc ça veut dire que le plan il va
commencer dès le 1er janvier 2022 mais
jouer répondre sur la notion de on nous
fait le coup chaque année je sais
peut-être qu'on nous fait vous chaque
année mais on s'aperçoit que c'est sous
notre tous les cadres qu'inquiets tous
les quatre ans que la
ccc ccc notre quinquennat que que
l'emploi industriel est reparti on a
cinq cent mille apprentis on a créé
façon l'aide des emplois industriels et
on regrette justement qui est une
désindustrialisation de la france alors
un moment donné c'est bien d'être dans
l'interjection et de dire
yakafokon etc mais quand on est aux
manettes d'un gouvernement et qu'on a
une attitude volontariste ça paye et ça
ça qu'il faut répéter aux français le
chômage baisse les entreprises
reviennent les usines se reconstruise
c'est ça le plan d'investissement est
effectivement sur des métiers d'avenir
plutôt que de regarder toujours dans le
rétroviseur quand même une des
caractéristiques principales d'une
certaine opposition politique bruno
bonnell c et ce plan d'investissement
finalement c'est pas si nouveau puisque
le 25 septembre 2010 est le gouvernement
avait présenté un grand plan
d'investissements
2018-2022 de 56 milliards d'euros
presque le double regardez tient à
l'époque c'était edouard philippe qui
était premier ministre écoutent et
le gouvernement a été missionné pour
mener à bien un projet de transformation
en profondeur de notre pays pour ce
faire nous avons décidé de nous appuyer
sur deux leviers d'abord le choix
d'engager des réformes économiques
fiscales et sociales ensuite nous
voulons amplifier l'effet de serre et
formant les accompagnons par des
investissements massifs avoir votre
réaction franck allisio bruno bonnell où
sont passés ces milliards 56 milliards
investis
d'abord vous n'êtes pas sans savoir qui
c'est passé deux trois trucs quand même
sur mac avec un canari saf investi on a
investi effectivement plusieurs dizaines
de milliards dans le soutien de
l'économie c'est sûr qu'entre de la
parole instantanée qu'on revisite canton
comme on refait le match cinq ans après
et
l'actualité qui a fait qu'il ya eu des
priorités qui ont été changés n'y a pas
de débat je vous répète il ya eu les 100
milliards du plan de relance qui ont été
effectivement dans la poche des gens les
gens l'ont vu les les cafés les bars les
entreprises les restaurants les gens
reçu des chèques donc c'est cet argent
n'a pas disparu et là il est temps de
réaccélérer pour le futur est lancé
c'est vraiment ça l'objectif de ce plan
france 2030 c'est pas de de l'équilibré
ce qui existe aujourd'hui mais de se
projeter dans l'avenir c'est ça la clé
est le pivot de ce plan franck 2030
alors se projeter dans l'avenir pour
l'opposition comme pour vous franck
allisio c'est une campagne électorale
déguisée dépenser beaucoup tout de suite
est-ce que c'est finalement pas un effet
immédiat d'un an dans l'opinion
franck allisio est en tout cas c'est le
but recherché par les équipes riches
mais vous comprendrez bien que
l'exécutif serait beaucoup plus crédible
si il avait fait dès le début du
quinquennat ce qu'il promet de faire
pour le prochain quinquennat parce qu'on
est là on est dans une promesse
électorale pendant ce quinquennat la
france est restée le champion du monde
de la pression fiscale le champion du
monde des dépenses publiques le champion
l'un dès champions du monde de la de
l'endettement la france est restée le
cocu du libre est chaude du système de
libre échange et c'est ça qui surtout
nous appauvrit la france a continué à
être vendue à la découpe le monsieur
dollar seul micro trottoir a eu raison
de rappeler évidemment la sphère alstom
et la france a continué à être l'un des
champions d'europe de l'immigration
subie l'immigration subie qui appauvrit
la france voilà le bilan économique et
social des manuels macron voilà pourquoi
il faut en changer en 2022 on va écouter
bruno le maire à présent le ministre de
l'économie qui a déjà expliqué fin
juillet le but de ce plan
d'investissement il s'agit de retrouver
notre indépendance
industriels at-il dit regardez il faudra
faire émerger les champions de demain
dans les secteurs qui dessineront notre
avenir l'ambition de ce plan
d'investissement est de retrouver notre
indépendance industriel et technologique
cette crise va accélérer les révolutions
technologiques de manière stupéfiante
notre sujet c'est ce renault une nation
leader sur les technologies de rupture
ou une nation cliente avec le président
nous voulons que la france soit une
nation de production de ces technologies
bruno bonnell ça va être difficile de
hisser à nouveau la france au niveau
industriel sachant que elle consacre ans
pour son pays mais c'est quasiment le
même niveau que la grèce 13 % par dont
11% pour la grèce on est on est très
très très en bas de l'échelle
écoutez pourquoi ça serait difficile à
moi ce serait difficile alors que la
france est reconnue pour la qualité des
ingénieurs la france est reconnue pour
la qualité et ses performances dans
certains domaines le spatial le
nucléaire pourquoi ça serait
systématiquement difficile pourquoi on
continuerait à penser que notre france
ces espèces de france désespéré qui part
dans le mur et qui n'a aucun avenir nous
nous croyons une france d'avenir nous
nous arrêtons de dire les phénomènes de
décla moi j'ai écouté tout à l'heure au
moins aussi le micro trottoir et j'ai
entendu des gens se disaient des choses
beaucoup plus nuancée que ce que je
viens d'entendre qu'ils disaient oui la
france est aussi un pays dans lequel on
arrive à avoir l'accueil on arrive à
avoir des choses vous savez un pays
comme le nôtre j'ai entendu pression
fiscale 50 milliards 50 milliards sur
notre sur notre pression fiscale 25 pour
les entreprises 25 pour les particuliers
des deux mois sur ce quinquennat donc
faut arrêter de dire des sornettes sous
faut arrêter de ne pas avoir envie de se
relever les manches la france que la
mienne en tout cas celle que je soutiens
c'est une france qui regardent devancé
celle qui a qui se rappelle également qu
on a été capable de bien des tgv des
concorde par la détermination de l'état
à dire on y va moi je crois dans dans la
dynamique française et j'en ai un petit
peu assez tentant toute la journée que
la france est en déclin alors que je
pense rigoureusement le contraire je
crois qu'on est très nombreux dans ce
pays à penser qu en se relevant les
manches et en relevant la tête la france
pour retrouver une place dans les
technologies de demain pour retrouver
cette place franck allisio faut-il
reconquérir la souveraineté économique
et industriel et bien évidemment parce
que ce que ce que disait tout à l'heure
bruno le maire il n'y aura pas de
champions nationaux il n'y aura pas de
champions européens tant que l'on
n'engagera pas un vrai bras de fer avec
l'union européenne puisque l'union
européenne interdit on sait depuis vingt
ans la constitution de ses champions
nationaux et européens et là seulement
il est le seul moyen d'engager ce bras
de fer c'est d'appliquer la politique
européenne recommandé par marine le pen
c'est à dire un véritable bras de fer
avec une technocratie européenne qui
depuis longtemps n'est plus au service
et des peuples européens et dans
l'intérêt des nattes des nations
européennes mais dans une idéologie de
libre échange de deux libéralismes
technocratique qui nous empêche de faire
justement ce dont parle monsieur bonnel
c'est à dire des tgv
ddd des programmes comme ariane qui
étaient des programmes de coopération
gouvernementale et pas d'une
technostructure hawks et l'oise alors
j'aurai juste aller sur les tpe pme
puisque ça représente plus de 80%
justement de l'industrie française
depuis 2010 est oui est ce que dit
marine le pen
les tpe et pme seront notre priorité ce
sont elles qui verront urgemment baisser
leur fiscalité pour recréer de l'emploi
franquet lésion est ce que c'est
toujours dans le programme de marine le
pen
sur la fiscalité plus tôt peut-être
d'injecter de l'argent pour redorer
l'industrie française
oui plus que jamais c'est la priorité
des priorités pour créer la richesse
pour encourager la création de richesses
et on est de baisser de baisser les
officiels à la pression sur les tpe et
les pme est tellement dans les classes
moyennes et populaires qu'elle est quel
est votre avis bruno bonnell est-ce
qu'il faut agir aussi sur les charges
qui pèsent
sur
les chairs de lyonnaise et sur les
normes aussi qui pèse beaucoup pour les
tpe domaine et je crois que on a
l'impression qu'on a une espèce de
parenthèse magique la wii s'est rien
passé pendant ce quinquennat c'est
rigoureusement le contraire il ya eu une
baisse de pression fiscale sur les pme
vient de le dire il ya eu 25 milliards
d'économies de pression fiscale sur les
entreprises et 25 milliard sur les
particuliers il ya aussi une réalité
c'est que j'ai entendu une seule heure
il faut rejeter l'europe se diamal
technocratique mais quand on parle de
lancer des fusées dans l'espace quand on
parle d'organiser des centrales
nucléaires de nouvelle génération
on a besoin de s'allier avec dé nos
alliés européens les etats unis c'est
pas la france la chine c'est pas la
france en termes de puissance de
d'invention technologique en main dont
fabrique un million d'ingénieurs par an
c'est à dire c'est à dire des milliers
de fois plus ce que nous autres ce que
ce que nous faisons en france donc
arrêtons de faire croire que c'est que
ces échelles d'investissement sont
limités soit des tpe pme soit à l'état
français on a besoin d'une collaboration
quant au soutien aux tpe pme je pense
que quand on regarde le plan sur les
indépendants notamment convient de
présenter nul gouvernement n'a fait plus
pour soutenir les tpe pme et encore une
fois c'est pas de l'interjection c'est
du concret c'est pas on va faire si on
fait et je crois qu'ils vont reconnaître
et donner le crédit aux gouvernements de
s'intéresser justement à cette relance
économique à l'emploi parce que c'est un
cercle vertueux qui permettra justement
par la croissance de sortir du phénomène
de la dette dont dont on sait qu'elle
est importante et qu'il faut absolument
l'éliminer dans les années qui viennent
pourraient retrouver la place de la
france en matière d'industrie la
recherche très important franck adhésion
que faut-il faire pour redonner en tout
cas plus de moyens à la recherche
déjà toujours pareil un bbb c'est la
baisser la pression fiscale baissé aussi
tout ce qui les les règlementations ce
qu'on appelle l'impôt papier qui
complique la vie y compris des
chercheurs en l'aso on l'a souvent vu je
veux juste revenir sur les baisses
d'impôts que ce bonnet le répète et
répète non il ya eu des baisses d'impôts
selon pareil pour les grandes
entreprises et pour les contribuables
les plus riches les 0 1% et se baisse
sur les très riches et les très grosses
entreprises qui compense les hausses
d'impôts sur les classes moyennes les
classes populaires les tpe et les pme
donc donc évident à fins etc la justice
fiscale avait avec son gouvernement et
line et fès l'inefficacité économique et
social je vous laisse répondre très
court bruno venait lui nous resterons de
ce compte écoutez je ne sais pas où vous
monsieur à trouver des hausses d'impôts
moi je crois que la taxe d'habitation
notamment pour les ménages la très
faible et à paqueter les gens qui
étaient vraiment modeste et enfin encore
une fois croyez en la france monsieur
moi j'ai quelque chose à vous dire c'est
croyez dans une france qui a envie de se
relever les manches et arrêtons de
parler des déclinistes et de faire de la
politique sur les emplois de demain les
emplois de nos enfants nos enfants ont
besoin de re croire en la france c'est
notre responsabilité d'homme politique
de leur dire oui il ya une sortie
possible il rien et désespéré en tout
cas c'est pour ça que je fais de la
politique
merci beaucoup franck allisio et merci à
vous bruno bonnell d'avoir répondu ce
matin à nos questions sur rt france on
va écouter évidemment le chef de l'état
à partir de 10h pour ce plan
d'investissement de 30 milliards d'euros
c'est la fin de set